In the case of a fully virtualized
hypoviser, the guest operating system has no knowledge
of machine pages. It thinks that it's physical
memory is contiguous because it is thinking that
it is running on bare metal, nothing has
been changed in the operating system to run
on top of a hypervisor in a fully
virtualized setting. And therefore, it is the responsibility
of the hypervisor to maintain the PPN to
MPN mapping. In a para virtualized setting, on
the other hand, the guest operating system knows
that it is not running on bare metal.
It knows that there's a hypervisor in between
it, and the real hardware. And it knows,
therefore, that its physical memory is going to be
fragmented in the machine memory. So the mapping PPN
to MPN can be kept in either the guest OS or the Hypervisor. But, usually,
it is kept in the guest operating system. We'll talk more about that later on.